lauren bober radical republican
congresswoman lauren bober
has shifted from the relentless attacks
on electric vehicles
to attempt to limit access to certain
types of firearms now there's a lot of
this sky is falling stuff from the right
on electric vehicles we heard yesterday
from marjory taylor greene if everybody
gets an electric vehicle it's going to
be a dystopia and there's not going to
be any power there's going to be
blackouts people will die there will be
no food it'll be crazy and we debunked
that piece by piece yesterday
lauren beaubert her sort of comrade in
arms as we might call it even though i
don't know that they really like each
other that much despite whatever they
might want to believe they are quite
similar in many ways she's going after
gun bans and lauren bobert said
yesterday that if you ban assault
weapons not even if you ban all guns if
you ban assault weapons and people still
can have handguns people are going to
end up eating dogs here in the united
states
what
listen living her life providing a crust
for your employees providing for your
family why did you do what you did in a
public forum in front of that politician
why did you feel the need to stand up
yes so dr gorka um my upbringing i lived
under failed policies i lived in a
democrat household and i saw firsthand
the policies of her own parents in that
democrat household
where her parents distributed food to
all the kids even though the kids
weren't working she was living under
democratic socialism in her own home
okay it's firsthand how restrictive
their policies are there's not a lot of
liberty uh under democrat rule in fact
it left us in uh breadlines waiting for
government cheese and i knew that that
was not america's best they give out
cheese in the bread line can you believe
that that sounds unorganized 11 years
old so i started working as a young
teenager at a mcdonald's and learned
that i could do a better job taking care
of myself than government did now fast
forward my i have a husband four
wonderful boys and a restaurant and a
lot of employees vendors patrons the
restaurant has closed that i needed to
take care of and i saw the second
amendment to be the best
line of defense to make sure everyone
was kept safe in my establishment now i
am a petite woman and i need an
equalizer i need a an equalizer to
protect me against a larger potential
aggressor and when beta o'rourke told
the world the democrat playbook hell yes
we intend to take your ar-15s and your
ak-47s i was compelled to go to him
because i saw that a disarmed populist
if the citizenry in america is disarmed
then we are no longer citizens we are
subjects you know here in america we
have gourmet treats for puppies we have
uh these amazing groomers for dogs well
in venezuela they eat the dogs and it
started because they don't have firearms
they do not have a way to protect
themselves to defend themselves against
a tyrannical government now
a great way to test this hypothesis
no assault weapons leads to eating dogs
would be to look at the countries around
the world where you can't get assault
weapons and
they're really not eating dogs in any of
those countries now i know that there
are
a few countries where dog meat is eaten
and we've talked about some of those
countries before and those countries
have a sort of varying gun legislation
but by and large i i looked
there is no correlation between
dog eating and bans on all weapons guns
never mind specifically assault weapons
this is yet another one of these scare
tactics they don't know what to do next
it's but it's gotten to a point with the
gun stuff
where
the country is ready to say
let's try doing something with the guns
now not everybody and certainly not our
elected officials but at this point most
people don't think the issue is just
mental health most people don't think
the issue is just doors or ladders or
staircases or fire escapes or whatever
else
at some point
many people are going to say i don't
love it necessarily but let's at least
try dealing with the guns they may they
being republicans they may lose the
midterms because of their unwillingness
to do anything as far as the guns go and
so now they're coming up with you know
if we ban the guns you're going to be
eating you're going to be eating sparky
sparky's going to be barbecued if we get
rid of guns and of course it's absurd
and they're desperate to prevent
anything being done about the guns now
will anything be done about the guns
remains to be seen
one of our sponsors today is bluechu a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence
when it's time
all you have to do is take a short quiz
on their website a licensed doctor
approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discreet package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of blue chews tablets are made in
the usa the entire process is just a few
clicks
go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping